Taylor Swift is now a billionaire she's
become a billionaire because of that
concert tour that she went on last year
the Aras
tour
I other than on this show when my
producers have made me do it I don't
think I've ever consciously listened to
a Taylor Swift song I'm sure I would
recognize some of them if I if they came
on the radio but I the the one that
comes to mind is is uh I'm the problem
it's me cuz we did it on show but I I I
just haven't paid attention to Taylor
Swift and yet when she launched her tour
and I came into the office all the girls
in this office were on their computers
this is I don't know when it was right
right after my show first thing in the
morning they're refreshing Ticket Master
because they've got the American Express
extra pass to to buy the tickets early
and the tickets were a bazillion dollars
and they were they were so excited so
what I have friends of mine female
friends very serious women very normal
people went crazy for Taylor Swift paid
lots of money and inconvenienced
themselves to go see the show I didn't
get it but obviously 50 million
Frenchmen can't be wrong the the tour
has brought Swift's net worth to $1.1
billion according to Bloomberg why is
it I think I'll expand on this I'll even
expound on this in in the coming days
and weeks but I I think the reason that
Taylor Swift is singularly successful
probably the most powerful woman on
earth right now is because she's
basically
normal she is
pretty she's not she's not a runway
model she's pretty she sounds pleasant
she's not uh not
Mozart and she's not pavara but she
sounds pleasant enough to totally
inoffensive she doesn't have a ton of
tattoos she doesn't have crazy hair she
doesn't
have a million weird piercings she's
just she doesn't go Screech and scream
all that if she has political views
they're
relatively mildly stated she just she's
just normal and nice and
pleasant and for much of our nation's
history that would have made Taylor
Swift totally unexceptional no one would
know her name but at this moment which
is so absurd which is so insane which is
so divorced from reality just a little
bit of normal is refreshing and desired
and if you are that normal person you
can make a billion dollar apparently
right now go to medishare.com as a
dailywire listener you are informed and
engaged and handsome you value your
freedom your way of life your personal
responsibility that's why you got to
check out Medishare Medishare is a
community- based approach to healthcare
that lines up with the principles you
believe in your beliefs matter and with
Medishare your healthare dollars will
not be used for medical procedures that
don't line up with what you believe in
Meda share is the highest rated
Healthcare sharing Ministry with a
30-year proven track record members save
up to 50% or more on their monthly
healthcare costs and member satisfaction
surveys show that they like Meda share
much more than health insurance why
because it works for a limited time
daily wire listeners will receive a $150
gift card when they join Medishare to
find out more go to medishare.com that
is medishare.com
Michael terms and conditions apply do
not wait head on over right now get that
$150 gift card when you join it is
medishare.com
micel Jens saki is attacking Mike
Johnson the new conservative leader of
the House of Representatives because
Mike Johnson is a Christian the Bible
doesn't just inform his worldview it is
his worldview in fact during his first
speech in his new job Johnson suggested
that his election as Speaker was an act
of God talk about a bit of a humble brag
there so what exactly has God apparently
called on Mike Johnson to do well his
views on policy are essentially what
you'd expect from a religious
fundamentalist they're more divisive
than they are
Divine so this reminds me obviously of
when Diane Feinstein rip uh made fun of
Amy Comey Barrett and attacked her by
saying that she she feared that the
Dogma lived loudly within her the
implication being that a Catholic should
not be on the Supreme Court maybe a fake
Catholic is okay like like a Joe Biden
type or a Nancy Pelosi type but an
actual practiceing Catholic should not
be permitted on the Supreme Court uh
this reminds me of when Joy Bahar mocked
Mike Pence I think it was for it was it
was some conservative at least for
believing that he would speak with God
and he said oh joy beor said that's
that's crazy maybe you can pray to Jesus
but once Jesus starts talking back then
that's when you got to worry like like a
anyone who prays is a crazy person and
you see that same kind of ignorance here
with Jens saki says this this guy he
think this this man who is in a position
of civil Authority he thinks he was he
was placed there by God which is a a
very basic Christian belief St Paul
writes about this in the letter to the
Romans that the Civil Authority is given
to us by God for the execution of
justice and for our own
good if you are a Christian of any sort
you most certainly believe in Providence
the notion that that God has a plan that
unfolds throughout history ours is a
very historical religion it in fact
there's a pivot of History known as the
Incarnation and the crucifixion and the
resurrection this is like Christianity
101 folks and and what's shocking here
is not that a liberal would make fun of
Christianity they tend to be opposed to
Christianity and fact the very terms
left and right come from the French
Revolution when the Christians sat on
the right side of the National Assembly
and the revolutionaries and the atheists
and the Liberals sat on the left side of
the assembly so that's been baked in for
a long
time what's what's shocking is the
ignorance and the kind of proud glib
ignorance that she would she would mock
this guy for being a Christian when she
clearly doesn't understand the first
thing about Christianity and then
there's this final little irony here
which is that the the Liberals are so
irate at the notion of of religious
politics one they are as sup the
Liberals themselves are as superstitious
as they come they think that a man can
become a woman and they think that a
baby can magically cease to a b be a
baby when the mother doesn't want him
but but beyond that they they suggest
suggest that they hate the idea of
religious politics and let me I promise
you to any liberals who might share that
view who are listening to the show right
now if you think religious conservatism
is bad just wait until you see
irreligious conservatism if you think
politics informed by True Religion
broadly is is not a great thing just you
wait until you see irreligious politics
just you wait to see how bad things can
get because everybody's got to serve
somebody so if you're serving God if
you're orienting your society and your
personal life toward the good you're
going to fail it's a fallen world but
you'll be headed in the right
direction if you're just turning away
from all that and you throw morality
aside and you ignore God and you you
pursue only that which is evil and
convenient man things can get bad real
fast man that was a great clip huh now
hey hey hey
stop ring that Bell subscribe to the
Michael nlls podcast we'll see you next
time